the size really matter when it comes to
your brain and what if the size of your
brain affected your intelligence what if
your brain was twice its size today on
what if discussed
[Music]
everybody welcome to what if discussed
I'm Peter speechin and I'm Richard
garner Pete how's your brain well it
depends what you mean I mean how do I
think I want it scale of one to ten and
my brain is a 10 now while my brains a 9
I think there's a little bit more that I
could pack into it but it treats me well
it serves me well I find I've I'm able
to navigate my way around the world to
reminded me of Jerry Seinfeld and
Costanza is about the head of lettuce
anybody takes George you've gotten a lot
out of this particular one what if I
told you I could increase the size of
your brain would you be interested I
would be interested why because I think
that would make me smarter am i right
well you'll have to tune in to the rest
of the show because it doesn't sound and
against bit complex I think the short
answer is no brain size intelligence
doesn't necessarily correlate but you
didn't tune in to hear that from Peter
and I we're gonna be talking to some
pretty big brains later in the show big
brains mean well by that I mean kind of
like back in the day when you talk about
like somebody like the great kazoo kazoo
the Flintstone pinkie in the brain
generally when we talk when we tried to
demonstrate intelligence in sci-fi or
cartoons what did we do
enormous brains enormous brain yeah well
again as you're kind of figuring out
already probably was not necessarily the
case in terms of making somebody smart
but we'll find out why I guess and we
will find out why I have a question for
you Oh excellent
if bigger brains did make you smarter
maybe you could only make one part of
your brain bigger what part of your
brain would you like to make bigger
that's a good one and I'm gonna go with
the cerebral cortex do you know why I
don't I don't know the names of the
other parts though so I'm like thinking
like so if you could make if you could
be better if one party your brain is
like better at math or like better at
building sheds or you know cooking or
something well if we're gonna get
serious and we are no discipline
I mean it I talk about that all the time
how were wired effects
we are there's very few people you're
ever gonna meet your life who aren't
their environment plus how they're wired
genetically neurologically very few we
do know now with neuroplasticity that we
can choose to actively rewire our brains
takes time takes effort it takes
repetition but it's generally hard
essentially who you were back in the day
is who you are now I'm somebody that's
terrible with discipline terrible with
organization terrible with sort of you
know being on time I know I'm really
painting a great resume here so if I go
in there with some with a wrench and
some pliers and fix that up so I was
like one of those you know you know you
know keep the Train on the track yeah
you know keep the trains running on time
in a way that that was came natural to
me which it doesn't that's what I would
choose you I would probably choose
building things I like to build things
but I don't really necessarily have the
knowledge of it but if I could increase
the size of my brain that tells me how
to you know figure out an angle from
looking at the you know there's so many
things that I don't know about building
and about so carpentry type things
really interests me but I don't really
get it
I'm sure I could just take some YouTube
tutorials but since we're on the subject
of brains I'd I'd increase the size of
that part of my brain so if you do get a
gift from Peter that is homemade anyway
so we'll talk about that more but this
show will include some pretty big brains
as we were talking about earlier but we
do have another big brain to talk about
a genius in fact right Peter yeah that's
right one genius that we can talk about
is policy genius the sponsor of today's
show policy genius is an insurance
marketplace and Richard do you have
insurance
I do not you well some people right now
are looking to buy insurance they have
dependents and they want to be able to
provide but in the midst of a pandemic
some people are thinking can I even buy
insurance
is it possible well the short answer is
yes policy genius will sell you
insurance but they don't just sell you
insurance they provide an insurance
marketplace policy genius compares
quotes from the top life insurance
companies all in one place just takes a
few minutes to compare quotes
from the top insurers to find your best
price and it doesn't really need to take
a lot of legwork you just start the
application and they take care of all
the paperwork and the red tape it saves
you a lot of time but you know what else
it would save you what's another thing
that you would like to save money money
of course so it's gonna save you $1,500
or more per year on insurance so I would
go to it so if you're one of the many
people looking to buy life insurance
right now but you're not sure where to
start
head to policy genius.com policy genius
will find you the best rate and handle
the process completely then they'll get
you and your family protected and
hopefully give you one less thing to
worry about right now cuz there's a
whole lot of things going on yeah lots
of lots of things to worry about these
days and I don't know about the rest of
you but saving me time saving me money
giddyup yeah honey money special huh so
let's get started on what if your brain
was twice its size okay let's get to our
guest Michio Kaku is one of the most
recognizable scientists in the world
popularizing subjects like physics
cosmology and futurism through his
hundreds of television appearances as
well as the multiple shows he himself
has hosted for the Discovery Channel BBC
and Science Channel
he's also authored a number of
best-selling books including beyond
Einstein physics of the impossible and
the future of the mind he currently
hosts the only nationally syndicated
science radio program in the u.s.
science fantastic
professor Kaku you've referred to the
brain before which you've talked about a
lot as the most complex object in the
known universe so I guess two questions
what do you mean by that and is that
still the case yes that is still the
case the champion who are the most
complex object in the universe sits on
your shoulders we have scanned the
universe out to tens of billions of
light years we see first of all no
evidence of life no evidence of
intelligent life complex object consists
of a hundred billion neurons that sits
on your shoulders now of course we can
debate how well you use that brain but
but yes the brain is the most complex
object in the known universe
professor people have always referred to
people with big brains or always
imagined people with big brains as
having more intelligence but how much
does size really matter in terms of the
brain size is only marginally important
with respect to intelligence and the
brain think of the brain of a whale the
brain of a whale weighs five times more
than a human brain also the Neanderthal
the Neanderthal had bigger brains than
us and main on average had slightly
bigger brains than females but I can
think of a lot of females who are
probably more intelligent than a lot of
meals that I know and so if you take a
look at size it's not the size so much
is the composition and the use of the
brain that makes all the difference so
people also know you as a theoretical
physicist
you can obviously speak to a bunch of
different subjects including neurology
the brain etc but connect those two
things how much has physics helped us
better understand the brain in terms of
the development of that technology MRIs
etc over the last 20-30 years
well the thing used to be a black box we
didn't know anything about
we just basically just work and doing
autopsies now with MRI scans we can
actually see the living brain in motion
we can actually see thoughts you're
saying across the brain we can actually
see ideas as they are formed inside the
living brain now the most important part
of the brain is actually the front of
the brain that's the prefrontal cortex
that's where you are actually doing
computations right now truely's and
computations even as I speak right
behind your forehead now we realize
therefore the different parts of the
brain do different functions the back of
the brain is the so-called reptilian
brain the brain of balance the brain of
a sexuality hunger territoriality that's
the back of the brain the middle part of
the brain is the monkey brain the limbic
system that governs emotions that
governs your hierarchy in the tribe but
the front of the brain is the most
important that measure is time you want
to know about intelligence talk to your
dog tonight and teach your dog the
meaning of tomorrow you can't you can't
explain tomorrow to an animal that's
where the prefrontal cortex comes in the
people in the cortex is a time machine
constantly saying what if what if I did
this what if I did that we're dogs it's
just we don't get my next meal so a
couple of monkey brains right here today
I'm hosting a show I would suspect less
use of the prefrontal cortex but you be
the judge at home now this is a good
sort of segue because you've kind of
bridged now between the brain and the
mind a lot of people confuse those
things they think they're sort of
interchangeable your seminal book the
future of the mind you know opened up a
lot of minds around the world about the
potential not only that we have now but
looking into the future talk about the
difference between the brain and the
mind well we
got something called dualism during the
Middle Ages where your soul was separate
from your being and then during in the
last hundred years we had the
development of neurology and
neurologists said Wow
humbug there's no separation of the mind
and the body
this has neurons that's all it is just
neurons out there now we're going back
to the Middle Ages we now realize that
the mom we're and the brain is wetware
and you can separate the two in fact
even after your body dies your your
software can continue to live on forever
this is called digital immortality the
fact that the mind will survive the body
itself and in fact I think the future of
the mind is brain net the future of the
internet is not going to be digital at
all it's going to be thoughts we will
simply think and have our thoughts
spread around the world when you go into
a room and communicate on the web you
will simply think and telepathically
communicate to the people of the world
when you want to see a movie movies are
going to be obsolete who wants to see a
screen with sound when you can
telepathically feel the emotions of the
actors and actresses so brain net I
think will replace the internet and we
will mentally communicate mentally
download thoughts communicate our
thoughts to the rest of the world so the
future of the Internet is brain net so
you're saying the brain is just a big
organic computer waiting to be
downloaded by waiting to have things
downloaded into it how how exactly would
that work
well when you go to the library today
you get a book about Winston Churchill
in the future when you go to the library
you will talk to Winston Churchill
there'll be a holographic image that has
all the mannerisms of witness in
Churchill all the memories letters
speeches stored inside the memory of the
computer I would love to talk to
in style I would love to talk to a
digitized version of Einstein that has
access to all his letters all his
interviews all his writings everything
and I think one day we will communicate
with our great-great-great
great-great-great grandchildren and they
will communicate with us because we will
be digitally immortal that our thoughts
our mannerisms our deepest feelings will
be encoded and the library will become
not just a library of objects but a
library of souls that you'll be able to
access the hopes and dreams of your
ancestors and basically talk to your
descendants that's the future of the
Internet and when we do this with an
implant to the brain how will how
exactly will it come about well right
now we do it with implants to the brain
we can put a chip right on top of the
brain and allow you to control an
exoskeleton for example during the San
Paolo soccer games a few years ago the
man that kicked the football initiating
the soccer games was totally paralyzed
at Duke University they put a chip in
his brain connect him to an exoskeleton
that allowed him to walk and allowed him
to kick the football initiating the
games so today we do it with implants
perhaps when we're born perhaps when
we're born we're going to be hooked up
to brain net so what simply think of it
as part of daily life the fact that we
can simply think and our wishes come
true we can download any movie any piece
of information communicate with anybody
and download entertainment and all the
emotions that come along with it and so
I think that's going to be the future
the future when brain-dead basically
becomes our entry into the universe wow
there's some big ideas and but hard not
to see the way we're going forward one
of the things that's talked about a lot
these days is the difficulty let's say
with
understanding other people empathy
really is is a problem that has been
around for a long time and
intellectually we can try to empathize
with somebody else but truly until you
as they say walked a mile in somebody
else's shoes you can't know them you
can't know it's informed all of their
decisions their conditioning do you see
some of what you're talking about being
able to finally maybe activate the part
of our brain that can truly empathize
with another human being yes I think one
benefit of brain-dead is that you will
be able to feel the suffering of other
people if you simply read about the
suffering of other people you can say
come on give me a break I mean really
however if you could feel the anguish
feel the emotions of other people then
of course there's a whole new dimension
there now on one hand teenagers will
love it
because they'll be able to put the
emotion of their first kiss their first
date right after every sentence right
now they put a happy face after every
sentence right in the future going to
put into motion after every sentence and
communicate with your other teenage
friends four adults will be able to
empathize and be able to understand
where other people are coming from that
it's not a dry act going through the
statistics of discrimination this is
six-six of inequality know you'll be
able to feel what other people are
feeling and that's the difference
between brain net and the movies the
movies is nothing but a screen with
sound that's hit a screen with sound in
the future you'll have emotions feelings
memories along with the image so it's an
incredible thing we start off by asking
a question what if our brains were twice
the size and finding out that it doesn't
necessarily correlate to intelligence
but what we out found out too though is
we're at the tip of the iceberg for not
only understanding the brain but what
we're going to be able to do as a
species when we better understand and
develop our neurological capacities I
never fail to be
slack-jawed after talking to you dr.
Kaku it was great to have you on today
where can people find your work these
days I know you're doing that you're
doing television your own podcast where
do you point people that want to find
out more about the work that you're
doing well go to my website and Kaku dot
org MK aku org it has references to for
find New York Times bestsellers plus
interviews that I've done in the past
and well I'm on national radio on about
a hundred radio stations across the
country and the internet every week so
you can tune in but first go to my
website MK aku org we also have about
three million fans on Facebook
well we're big fans obviously here at
what if about making science more
accessible I would put you on the Mount
Rushmore of people that have done that
over the last you know two twenty thirty
years and will continue to do so going
forward thanks again for your time
thanks for the great work that you're
doing keep keep it up we'll see you down
the line okay thank you thanks professor
so Richard mine is not hurting because
my brain power is not smart enough but
I'm thinking maybe after all that
information maybe does your brain hurt a
little bit yeah that's that's definitely
not like popsicle brain freeze level but
yes I mean this that's it's not drinking
out of a firehose exactly but I mean
when you're talking a guy like Nietzsche
Oh Kaku I mean for him this is nothing
he's talking about brain net like he's
talking about the weather you know yeah
it's like we're almost like what sorry
can you back up and when you're talking
about first of all when you're talking
about the brain that's wildly
fascinating and deep then when you get
into the future of the brain and
downgrading fastening and integrating
the brain with other whatever and it's
it's not like our sci-fi hasn't been
going down this you know for for a long
time with cyborgs and and and and even
even holograms like it's interesting the
idea that he's talking about they're
about going to the library right one day
so I'll ask I'll ask you this yeah we
know we can clone right we know Dolly
the sheep back in the day we haven't
clone humans please we know we've gray
humans but whatever
for this show we're gonna pretend we
don't know we've cloned humans but let's
say we clone humans one day we know we
can probably do that and let's say one
day according to Michio Kaku that you
can download essentially Peter speech
ins entire every thought you've had
every every every single sort of picture
everything every memory fair enough I
believe that and you were integrate okay
you take a clone Peter organic clone
Peter you take the download and insert
that into this is that you it's not me
why because well first of all because I
am me so it would be it could be Amara
it would be a replica of me but even
apart from that I still have the power
of future thought of continuing to think
I'm guessing he would only have my past
experiences yeah so he wouldn't be able
to think on his feet he like if I asked
him you know I don't even know what a
question I would have asked twenty year
old me twenty years I could before now
me but like would he be able to think on
his feet and just give me an answer like
what what do you see yourself doing in
the future I guess I would have known
that it would have been in my brain
somewhere I suspect it feels like
probably just really advanced AI right
where you're gonna see wow that's
impressive relative to a human yeah but
it's not exactly a human for those but
there's those intangible qualities that
I would also say whether it was data on
Star Trek next generation or whatever
road they go down and trying to do that
it's there's always some sort of you
know some people say it's consciousness
some people might say it's a soul
whatever it is there is some sort of
differentiation between just the
information in the hard drive and the
flesh but something more to us it's the
mind yes that's what we were gonna add
what she talked about there is a
difference between the brain and the
mind which is interesting one of the
things he's also a proponent of he sees
it as a positive you know the sort of
the rakers well singularity stuff which
people have talked about for a long time
if that's not something you're familiar
with
I mean it's essentially the integration
of us with technology now he references
the pause
that that cyber cyber skeleton that
people are using for people with missing
limbs now so for instance you can
connect somebody and all of a sudden
they have the use of their legs through
these sort of prosthetics or cyber
skeletons and all that so some people
see that as a real positive but he's
like full-bore like that we at some
point will be sort of integrated like
he's talking chips in the head he's
talking that's fantastic too and the
thing that I was thinking about that is
okay would be great just like talking to
matrix you know you could you could
download you know karate or kung-fu or
whatever in a day but also doesn't it
give you the opportunity to separate
humanity from the haves and the
have-nots so people who can afford to
have those chips implanted in their
brain become the leaders of the free
world or if it's still a free world the
of this soon to not be free world and if
you don't have the cash to you know
upload you know the University of
London's law degree you you you're not
on the same plane as somebody who has
money so I think it creates a big divide
of rich and poor not sure if I'm if I'm
exactly right here but it does sound now
that you mention it that I believe was
the the premise of Strange Days with it
was Angela Bassett and the guy that was
in Schindler's us anyways the point
being was a sci-fi movie where exactly
that the rich people were the only
people who could afford these massive
upgrades creating a much bigger divide
between the haves and have-nots wow I
didn't see that movie yeah it's a good
like I'm not a hundred percent sure if
that's the entire premise but again
we've we've gone down these row these
roads through science fiction but every
time you're talking to somebody like me
choukaku you're like that stuff's not 20
years from now 50 years ago ten years
from now it sounds like we're on the
cusp of some of these things right now
well all I can say is I look forward to
seeing what happens and I don't doubt
any of this is gonna happen I just don't
I mean you can't picture it because your
brain is not hasn't got there yet as
they say when we get that information we
will bring it to you join us on
next what if discussed if you liked this
episode and want to spend more time on
the topic click on the link in the
description below and check out our
extended audio version will be talking
with award-winning medical science
writer Rita Carter about how having
bigger brains leads to bigger problems